Kathy what are some fatal errors that a
writer should avoid at all costs Wow I I
think one of the things that you you
need to know that it's not just one
script you have to think about your
whole career that you don't just bank
all your hopes on this one piece of
material you have to be working
constantly and that things don't happen
just like that one of the things I did
I'm in my book is I took a survey
I asked all of these writers who came
into the studios and that I worked with
I asked them you know a couple of
questions and one of them was how long
did it take you how many scripts that
you have to write before you either
before something major happened like you
got an agent or that you got an option
or somebody bought something I
interviewed over 200 professional
writers these are not waiter writers
these are professional writers only one
got her script sold the first script Wow
and she said it took five years for her
to get a second sale yeah and the
average actually turned out to be eight
or nine eight or nine scripts of scripts
okay Wow so it's it's if you have to
love what you do you don't want to be a
one script lender it doesn't happen very
often where somebody only writes one
script and that's it and then nothing
they have to be writing constantly and
that's what agents and you know and
executives are looking for and producers
are looking for they want to build a
relationship you'll notice that people
like Spielberg and all the all the big
directors you notice they'll all have
the same credits the same same people
for you know cinematographer script
supervisor you know and they go to some
of the same writers because they have
built a relationship with them because
they like their kind of storytelling
because their characters speak
the same language that they would like
to convey to you know movie viewers and
so being able to have those kind of
relationships it's not just writing it's
also writing the kinds of things that
are going to continue that relationship
so I love the fact that that most of the
writers nowadays have a better
understanding of that and they when I
when I see them at like script fest or
great American pitch fest when I ask
them I always ask them you know what
else are you working on just to test
them nowadays most of them will say that
they have more than one that they're
working on so I guess it's working I
guess they are getting the getting that
news that you need to have more than one
piece of material
you